CES has been tracy has been covering the
summit he's based here in Asia and he
joins me now bend at me Kim jong-un and
the North Korean press have been talking
about him coming home with something in
hand how is he positioned today it's
gonna be interesting to see how North
Korea positions this because as you said
just a couple of hours before this
summit took place North Korean state
media put out this report basically
saying that they were expecting
epoch-making results from this summit
that clearly didn't happen Kim Jong moon
would obviously like sanctions relief
but you know all along the skeptics have
said that North Korea is really just
playing for time here that they're not
serious about denuclearization that what
they really want is just to be accepted
as a nuclear power and so Kim jong-un
has now been normalized to an extent by
meeting with the president United States
twice he seems more reasonable because
he's not firing off those those missiles
every other week which he was doing not
too long ago so he might be playing a
long game here he might have come into
this summit asking for full sanctions
relief knowing full well that wasn't
going to happen it's a fair point I mean
that the offer that kim jonghwan did
make it is a significant one this Manton
the Jung Hyung facility is not nothing
but it wasn't enough for president truck
right I mean this really is the heart of
North Korea's nuclear program this is a
massive facility you're talking about
almost 400 buildings spread over 3.4
square miles so if they really were
going to shut it down entirely
that would be huge but the Devils in the
details there you need inspectors to
come in to really verify that North
Korea has done that it would take a very
long time to do it so there would be a
lot of questions about that I mean I was
in North Korea last year when they
brought a bunch of journalists up to
their nuclear test site they made a big
show of blowing up the entrances to the
test tunnels but to this date North
Korea has never let inspectors in to
actually verify that what they say they
did is true and not
it's the verification are they doing
what they said they would do they
couldn't come to an agreement let's go
back to you Gail in New York
all right market Brennan to be continued
for sure things didn't seem to go
according to plan